hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
consideration in the use of analytical
ultracentrifugation
for characterization of aav gene therapy
delivery factors my name
is akash bhutacharya and i will be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by beckmann coulter life
sciences
please note that the optima auc is not
intended
or validated for use in the diagnosis of
disease
or other conditions also
the views expressed in this webinar are
those of the speaker
and not of beckman culture life science
for more information on beckman culture
please visit
www
resources before we get started
we'd like to get to know our audience
with a couple of questions
the first question is analytical
ultracentrifugation
or auc currently a part of your
analytical workflows
option a for yes an option b
for no the second question
are good manufacturing practices or gnp
important to your analytical workflow
needs
option a for very important option
b for somewhat important
option c for not very important
an option b for not sure
and finally the third question your work
environment
is best described as option a
for rnd or discovery option b
for process development option c
for manufacturing and option d
for quality control analytical
development
or characterization
thank you all for your answers with that
i would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the
ask a question box and click on the send
button also please notice that you can
share this webinar
on your personal social media just click
on the social sharing tab
to let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem
by clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus
offers continuing education credit
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr sucato associate director
of biophysical characterization at
charles river laboratories
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr sucato you may now begin your
presentation
thank you akash it's a pleasure to be
able to present this webinar today
on auc and gene therapy with a focus in
particular
in our charles river laboratories on aav
platforms
while in the past several mechanisms for
gene delivery
have been advanced as potential
therapies
and have held the promise of a stable
and long-term incorporation
of vector dna into host cells it's safe
to say that
at present at no associated viral
vectors
or aavs that is are indeed the leading
choice for gene therapy
the treatment for a variety of
conditions auc meanwhile
and the size distribution profiles that
derive from the sedimentation data
are becoming more and more a key
measurement in the aav development
process
what's contributed recently to the
success of aav based strategies
are some advances on the discovery and r
d side
and developing recombinant aavs with
clinically advantageous properties
optimized trans genes that are
efficiently delivered to the host cell
nucleus
and are reliably translated and on the
process and manufacturing
side likewise advances there that have
made aav
a practical drug material from a
commercial perspective
these developments scientifically are of
great value and interest i'm sure
to this audience and to the field in
general while a deep dive into many of
those aspects
would be beyond the scope of this
webinar i'll present a collection of
some references at the end
for anyone who may be interested
nevertheless
some of the recent advances in aav
technology can be understood in terms of
the schematic
illustrating how good manufacturing can
lead to a product with an improved
profile
in terms of the empty full and other
species
a critical quality attribute
incidentally which will be a focal point
of this presentation
but also favorable capsid properties
including
properties of the capsid shell the vp1 2
and 3 protein makeup
gained by recombinant expression
optimization
which can guide the tissue specificity
of initial receptor mediated endocytosis
the endocytotic process overall in the
cytosol
and likewise favorable properties of the
transgene
allowing for packaging of the maximal
gene size
and efficient stable incorporation in
the nucleus
the timeline shown here makes a good
case for why discussions like these
are particularly well timed it is only
recently after all
that clinical applications of aav have
begun to take off commercially
development pipelines expanding in
earnest really only in the last decade
and only two fda approved products at
present
but with many many more in development
pipelines globally
and regulatory guidance on the so-called
cqas
that define a safe and effective aav
product still taking form in many
respects
in this talk we'll discuss and
importantly show data also
in particular how recent advances in auc
characterization
of aav products may help inform that
type of guidance
now in the past at presentations like
this i've sometimes gone into some depth
about the history of aav its wild type
traits etc
that have led up to the present day
status of aav
as a gene delivery platform in the
interest of time i'll shorten that part
somewhat here
but suffice it to say there are indeed
plenty of review sources for this kind
of historical background
nevertheless briefly let me say that
wild-type aav
once thought to be simply a contaminant
of adenovirus preparations
was first characterized extensively as
early as the 1960s
as a unique viral species it was shown
to be replication defective
going through its full replication cycle
only if the host was co-infected with a
suitable
helper virus such as adeno or herpes
virus
an important observation at the time was
the finding that aav itself
only caused a mild immune response such
as the generation of
neutralizing antibodies and infection
did not produce any observable disease
condition
the apparent lack of pathogenicity in
the wild type was a main advantage that
would be leveraged in the development
of recombinant aav in gene therapy
other advantages are related to the
infection cycle of the wild type
for example in the latent phase aav
integrates itself stably
into the human genome at only a single
specific chromosomal site
and secondly aav has a good infectivity
rate with quiescent or non-dividing
cells
these advantages are in contrast to
retroviruses
which may present a random insertion and
mutagenicity risk
and are generally less effective in
non-dividing cells
now the wild type aav virion is itself
is a small
non-enveloped icosahedral particle about
20 nanometers in diameter
and one of the few disadvantages
incidentally to
aav is this small capsid geometry
and the relative size of the gene that
can therefore be packaged
the aav capsids contain a linear in the
wild type aav capsids
contain a linear single-stranded dna
genome of about 4.8 kilobase pairs
and wild-type aavs are replication
defective as mentioned
in other words they are they are
dependent uh in the wild type
on co-infection with a suitable helper
virus such as adenovirus
in order to complete their native
replication cycle
yet a recombinant aav has several
advantages as a gene
delivery vector it is safe it's not
known to be associated with any disease
symptoms
it's effective showing long-term
transgene expression
and it's also quite robust in many cases
being known to be
heat stable and showing stability under
storage conditions etcetera
now although the presence of a helper
virus is a requirement for aavs in the
wild type
when developed for use as a gene therapy
vector
production of recombinant aav not wild
type but recombinant av
can in fact be accomplished by
helper-free methods
where the necessary helper factors are
co-transfected
into the production cell line
additionally in most production schemes
such as this quite popular
and common uh triple co-transfection
method illustrated here
the wild-type aav genes for replication
and for the structural capsid proteins
are also co-transfected the repencap
genes are removed from the viral
target dna and only the therapeutic
transgene
sits between the inverted terminal
repeats
as illustrated in the capsid diagram
so there are a few different ways to
accomplish this endpoint
and what i mean by that is the purified
and concentrated end product as
illustrated at the bottom right of the
screen
so it's this purified drug substance as
it were that turns out
as as it turns out um there's a few ways
to accomplish this endpoint
uh the purified drug substance and as it
turns out
the exact modes of production and
purification
employed in the manufacture of
recombinant aav
can have an important influence on
attributes that appear to be critical to
the quality of the final product
one such critical attribute is related
to the nucleic acid that is packaged
within the capsids of recombinant aav
when produced from transfected cell
lines it has been shown that
recombinantly produced
aavs are not uniform with respect to the
packaging of dna into the core
a high percentage of capsids may contain
no genetic material at all
and would be termed empty capsids as
shown on the left hand side
additionally capsids have been shown to
contain incomplete portions or fragments
of transgene coding dna
or even non-target extraneous nucleic
acid contaminants
these species are illustrated on the
right hand side of the figure
so these observed empty or partially
filled variants of recombinant avs
can be dependent on the production and
purification method
and our critical quality attribute
because recent reports suggest
that the extent of empty or partial
capsids
in an aav drug products may correlate
with vector-related side effects
and reduced gene transduction rates
which are unwanted effects
from a drug product but yet other
reports hint at possible benefits
derived from having at least some
percentage
of the capsids in the drug product as
empties
so as i mentioned in the very first
slides a big part of gene delivery
characterization at charles river
is done by analytical
ultracentrifugation and i look forward
in just a few moments to getting into
some of the data
and the discussion associated with that
but i feel i must spend a little time on
the following question
shown here because it is something that
comes up all the time in our business
the question of just how to treat these
capsid related impurities
that invariably show up in aav drug
products empty capsids uh being
the most abundant in many cases
essentially though
how should the acceptability limits uh
the acceptable limit thresholds for
these species be set
what's clear from guidance documents is
that levels of empty capsids and other
capsid related variants
should be closely monitored that much is
beyond question
unfortunately there is no one answer as
to what levels of these impurities or
contaminants
would be considered an acceptability
threshold across the board for all av
drug products
instead a product specific assessment of
the empty full ratio
for these specific products as well as
the presence of partial species etc
should be done in correlation with
toxicology and potency data
obtained on the same sample type in
order to justify
any specific acceptability limits for a
specific
uh product line
while our focus in the biophysical group
at charles river
is the validity of the auc essay itself
we understand the importance of doing
this work
with some sense of where it all fits
into the overall regulatory approval
picture
and so i've included a few references
here towards that end
reference will certainly be of value to
anyone interested in regulatory guidance
this fda publication is from january of
this year
and is the latest guidance on cmc best
practices
and in particular section three two
p two two three as um
is uh excerpted here on the right hand
side
uh and the references and the discussion
in particular within that section
is important it gives the reader a sense
of how empty levels
should be defined and approached
just how to think of empties though is
still an active area of development
and this current opinion piece still
quite contemporary
presents some case for making the best
of drug products that do contain
significant levels of empties how these
products may still be moved forward
despite having empty levels that may be
significant
whilst here in a review from wright at
the university of pennsylvania
some of the downsides that mps may
present to av therapies
and the case for keeping empties low for
removing empties from
from drug products is covered
lastly here is a link to a very
informative discussion that was part of
a virtual think tank series recently
and has some very thoughtful insights
into how regulatory thinking may evolve
on the topic of gene therapy hosted by
some leaders
with regulatory experience
and so certainly um regulatory thinking
is evolving
um aav technology is evolving is
evolving in terms of the production and
purification strategies
so certainly you could say that
evolution or perhaps even revolution
is at hand judging by the development
pipeline for aavs
while as mentioned only two aav
therapies are fda approved at present
a great number of candidates will enter
into clinical trials in the near future
representing a variety of aav serotypes
and targeting a wide range of disease
conditions or target tissues as these
graphs make it clear
certainly given the rationale that the
see the species distribution profile
of these diverse products should be
carefully and individually
assessed in accord with talks and
potency data specific to these
these individual products the importance
of
methods like auc becomes apparent
which i think makes it a good time to
show you just indeed what auc can do
now the aec assay itself is by no means
trivial and we could spend
an entire webinar just on the
fundamentals of the sedimentation
process
instrument parameters and the data
deconvolution process
now suffice it to say the new optima
model of auc by beckmann coulter
presents the opportunity for improved
analysis
faster scanning easy setup of dual
absorbance and interference detection or
multi-wavelength studies
that can be done in a single experiment
and potentially improved signal to noise
and resolution as well
rotor parts rotors and cell parts remain
largely unchanged at present
and the fundamental data collected in an
auc experiment is shown here
in this graph the fundamental data
is the sedimentation profile that's
shown here generated by spinning these
special cells the special auc cells as
illustrated
at high centrifugal velocity causing
sedimentation of heavy species like
viral particles
now if the sample is highly mono
dispersed a single boundary region or
inflection will appear
as as is illustrated in the um
the trace um just above the
the cell diagram and the travel of this
boundary
will move from the top of the cell
towards the bottom over time
that travel is a function of the rotor
speed and the mass of the species
that's being sedimented now if the if
the sample is heterogeneous
each of the sedimenting species in the
sample
may contribute to the raw data in the
form of not just a single
boundary or inflection point but a
superposition of several different
boundaries
each proportional to the abundance of
the individual species
and the mass of that sedimenting species
numerical fitting algorithms take this
raw sedimentation data
and deconvolve it to a peak distribution
profile
such as the graph seen at the very far
right hand side
which we can readily observe and
quantify it's that final product
of that final data that we can look at
and quantify
now i've gone through these auc basics
rather quickly i admit
in favor of focusing the remainder of
the presentation
on showing some practical and real
results
many resources however are available to
dive deeper
into the fundamentals of the essay and
the fitting process
which i admit i have not talked about it
at great length
but a great review is one from professor
jim cole at the university of
connecticut
a paper from 2008 which is still very
relevant and
i must say a very good read so i
reference it here
but folks here is what a real auc
experiment
and setup here's what a real auc
experimental setup and result looks like
i should note that these data and all
results i'll show here after
derived from r d model auc samples these
are not data from clinical samples
nor drug products but are instead from
simple
r d model samples that nevertheless are
a good representation
of aav behavior
for this sample which i will refer to as
sample a we loaded about 150 microliters
at a titer of approximately 1 e to the
13th viral particles per mil
centrifugation was at 20 000 rpms
and detection was at 230 nanometers this
is an absorbance only detection mode
as you can see the sample concentration
in the instrument was about 0.5 od and
you can see that from the y-axis
of the rainbow colored curves
in the panel labeled a
and we collected about 60 scans which
collected over the course
of about four hours these results are a
series of sedimentation profiles that
again collected over time
each trace representing essentially a
single time point
and the data density or that term data
density
can be thought of as how closely spaced
these individual traces are
as i mentioned the movement of these
boundary regions gives you some sense of
the sample heterogeneity
and the relative size of the species in
the case of this sample because
there are apparently multiple boundaries
present clearly this sample
is not monodisperse there
may be more than one species present in
this sample
contrast the results on sample a with
those of sample b
which i show here this sample is also an
aav
incidentally sample b is of a different
serotype than sample a
but nevertheless very similar in many
respects
this sample was run on the auc in the
same exact way on the same auc
instrument the same exact way as sample
a
and we have a raw data set as shown here
some subtle differences
in the raw data do appear as you can see
if you contrast the data from a
and b there are multiple speeds there
are multiple boundaries
present in both but the amplitude and
the rate of travel might be
somewhat different
importantly when the fitted results are
observed as shown here for sample a
and here for sample b the difference
between the two is more readily
interpreted
and the value of auc becomes very clear
observe here at about 80 s a peak which
is an intermediate species
intermediate that is between the empty
and the full capsid species which are
labeled
this intermediate may correspond to a
partially filled
capsule species or or some other type of
variant
but nevertheless what's clear from these
two auc assays
is that the method is capable of
resolving
and quantifying the relative abundance
not only of empty and full which it does
quite well
but even intermediates with excellent
baseline resolution
and clearly auc can discern the
difference between
relatively small percent abundances
as i illustrate here in the partial peak
which
has a very distinctive difference
between its relative abundance in sample
a
and example b
now these samples may be from two
different stereotypes
but if you are developing an aav product
and are comparing two or more samples
as a result of a process change etc
the difference between this result
and this result may be significant to
your development decisions may be very
significant to your development
decisions
and it's good to know that auc can make
these kind of distinctions whether these
be different serotypes or from different
process changes etc
while some other methods like capillary
electrophoresis and ion exchange hplc
are indeed being developed for empty
full resolution
at present there is no method that can
surpass
the kind of resolution demonstrated here
for an aev sample
again showing excellent baseline
resolution
uh excellent and reliable baseline
resolution not only for empty and full
capsids but for intermediate species as
well
and possibly aggregates too towards the
right hand side
which we will get into
nevertheless the ability to resolve
subtle differences
in the abundance of small peaks as i've
just shown would only be reliable
if the method had sufficient precision
and of course precision
is a primary objective for any method
validation plan
so we've investigated what is the
expected precision
obtained for auc assays when applied to
aav
i show here a set of n equals six runs
done by the same analyst on the same day
and the statistics for the sedimentation
coefficient
and the peak area indicate that
precision by auc
is indeed quite fit for purpose both
both values both both s and percent area
having rsds
for those values that are quite
respectable
now admittedly chromatographic methods
are able to obtain
higher precision levels than shown here
for auc
hplc may have improved rsds over what's
shown here
but the kind of repeatability shown here
in both the statistical numbers
in the table and the relatively good
overlap between replicants
as evidenced visually by the graph
showing six overlaid
curves uh from the same six replicates
from the same sample
this would tend to argue that aac is
indeed very suitable for quantifying
empty and full levels especially given
the very good peak separation
shown here which is quite honestly
difficult to obtain by chromatography
and the longer term variability as we've
done as shown here by
intermediate precision whereby the same
sample was run
but on a second day second analyst the
second
second setup again supports the notion
that
that the auc when applied to aav samples
will kind of will have the kind of
precision both
in repeatability and longer term
intermediate precision
that you can count on for a validated
method
another parameter that we've evaluated
in our quest to determine
if auc can meet validation standards is
linearity
which i'll cover here we've actually
evaluated the linear response of auc
in two different ways first is by the
means i show in this slide where we have
run auc
on a series of samples we've created the
series by
by starting with the so-called full
capsid stock as shown
in the lighter purple color on the left
hand side
we've used that as a baseline and then
titrated in
known amounts of another stock which is
enriched in empty capsid that's the
darker purple color
on the right hand side of the schematic
by adding known amounts
of empty to a fixed and also known
amount of full capsids
we have the ability to challenge the auc
assay
in its capability to have a linear
response to a change
in the amount of one species relative
to another which remains relatively
fixed
and the data shown in the graph
indicates that
while the um while the species at 80 and
100s remain relatively
fixed in their in their um their peak
shape and size their percent abundance
the area under the curve for the empty
capsid
increases linearly in correspondence
with the amount of
empty caps that spiked in
the data indicate here that indeed
a good linear response is achieved and
this is a significant accomplishment
for the auc assay because this results
together with a reasonable value for
precision gives the analyst confidence
that small differences
in the empty full ratio will be picked
up by the instrument
a variation of the linearity challenge
to auc
is the ability to show a correlation
between
the total integrated area as a function
of the overall all amount of sample
loaded into the cell and this is what i
illustrate here
in this slide where we start with a
stock of
that full sample and then just do serial
two-fold dilutions downward from there
we've evaluated that kind of situation
by taking again as i say that stock
amount of sample and making the serial
two-fold dilution series
when we run that sample set in the auc
again we see a nice linear response a
nice linear trend
between the overall concentration loaded
in the cell
and the total integrated area under the
resulting distribution as the graph
shows
in area units as i say
the um the curve the curve for all
integrated species moving downward
linearly
in the total integrated area having a
nice one-to-one correspondence
between that measured area and the
amount that's loaded
this is good because it shows the
concept of recovery
which holds true for auc
in much the similar way that it would
for chromatographic assays
where one often does a sort of a mass
balance standard curve
in chromatography this is a reassuring
result
in auc
knowing the limits of detection in an
aec assay will also be important
to method validation in hplc
the lod and the loq would often be
defined by the signal to noise
such as the signal to noise in the
baseline of of a buffer blank
where the peak of interest would
normally appear
in a you see the baseline of a blank
scan is artificially smooth and very low
in noise
because the c vestis distribution the
the kind of graph that we're looking at
here
is really a fitted result this is not
this is not the noise from a detector
this is
this is the algorithm's attempt to fit
species in a certain region and if no
species are there to be observed
the noise is somewhat artificially low
therefore defining
lod and loq by this method would tend to
lead to values that are perhaps not
really realistic
for a limit of detection might be
artificially low
because the sedimentation profiles or
the raw data
should ultimately define the resolution
of
the presence of multiple species in
other words from the ability to resolve
different boundary regions
or inflection regions in a curve like i
show here
the noise in the raw data should be a
strong influence
on the ultimate the ultimate limit of
detection
of species in the district in the fitted
distribution profile
in auc we have in charles river we have
determined
calculated telod and loq by testing a
series of standards at low dilution
so very low dilutions of the stock
sample
in a manner similar to the slope
response analysis that one would do
in hplc using that method we find
limits of quantitation on the order of
about one percent
which is consistent with the noise level
in the raw scans like those shown here
part of any good validation will also be
robustness the demonstration
that the method can remain valid even
despite some usually small
perturbations in the method runtime
parameters
or if robustness is to fail then within
what limits
can robustness still be found we
challenge the auc
assay in this regard with respect to
these method perturbations shown here
and we found the following
with respect to the alignment of sample
cells in the rotor
there really is very little very little
room for error but we at charles river
have an alignment tool for the purpose
of cell placement in the rotor
and when used as directed data meets
precision expectations
in accord with what was shown several
slides earlier
in the presentation on precision however
if some amount of misalignment
is intentionally introduced as part of
the robustness perturbation
we find that even very small
misalignments as small as one to two
degrees
will lead to unacceptable data
sensitivity with respect to this
parameter is perhaps not surprising
since it has been reported for
protein-based systems
in earlier work i show some references
here
but we find in this work for larger
species like avs
which sediment relatively fast the
measurement
is especially sensitive to misalignment
and
there really is very little tolerance
for misalignment in auc work on aav
samples
an important finding that we've
discovered in our studies
with respect to the time allowed for
temperature equilibration
that is the time the rotor is allowed to
sit still or idle
in order that the rotor body and the
samples reach a temperature uniformity
throughout prior to spinning we do find
the method to be robust for wait times
greater than about 60 minutes
equilibration times shorter than this
can lead to unstable data
therefore wait times greater than about
one and a half hours
would usually be recommended for any
regulated work
the preset centrifugal velocity
parameter shown next
is generally quite robust when we dialed
in spin speeds that differed by plus or
minus 10 percent of the normal
of the nominal target velocity uh
results at these
at these slightly different spin speeds
uh still matched the expected results
from the nominal situation
lastly for robustness we have the scan
frequency parameter
which i must say is still in a very
active area of research in our
laboratory
while we have yet to fully evaluate the
effect of different scanning frequencies
or in other words the different data
density profiles
of the density of these individual
profiles that make up the raw data set
as you can see from the rainbow colored
curves how densely those are packed
we do know however that occasional scans
that may be missed
such as an occasional skipped scan that
may occur by the instrument
these occasional these occasional skips
do not perturb the data set
to any significant degree that is to say
the assay is still robust
for this type of occurrence and the
occasional skip scan by the instrument
another important finding to come out of
this work
and so the presentation thus far has
been geared towards showing
how the auc assay can meet many many if
not all of the criteria of a validated
assay
having reasonable results as i've shown
for precision
linearity and so forth results that make
the case that the auc
assay is indeed fit for the purpose of
judging the empty full ratio
and other properties but one overarching
characteristic
of the auc assay that must be present
these days
is the data integrity associated with
the measurement the
electronic records and the downstream
analysis
increasingly the expectation is that the
principles of so-called alcoa
attribute attributability legibility etc
illustrated here
that these principles are being held to
for any essay but certainly for those
assays that are you that are to be used
for lot release or
clinical samples
can the electronic records of an auc
assay attain these goals
the ac assay has not had the head start
in this area and that other assays like
hplc have had
auc of course has primarily been a
strictly r d
tool for most of its history but it's
been
it's been a very important tool it's
been a critical part of life science
research for many decades
but it has never until now really been
needed in a regulatory compliant way
with enough depth however any gaps we
feel can be overcome
and we at charles river have overcome
these gaps if one has computer systems
and i.t resources to leverage and create
workarounds where gaps do exist
and i list a few such solutions that can
be put in place
to lend some credibility uh some some
reliability and compliance i should say
as i show here in this table to the data
handling side
of the auc endeavor
importantly as i show here in a few
bullet points
csv and it groups can implement layers
of security
through add-on scripts to ensure
accessibility restrictions to the
software
adding a layer of security where the
software may presently
be lacking the custom scripts can also
be added
to make sure primary raw data once
generated
is automatically moved and is stored
read-only in a way that requires very
little intervention or interaction
from the from the from the analyst uh
the one who is logged in on the computer
we make this easier to cut we make this
easier and
secure through custom scripts but where
software gaps cannot be bridged by
electronic solutions we have reverted to
paper-based methods where we need to
including review checkpoints built into
the protocol
and a robust data form-driven process
for reporting which can show compliance
literally
every step along the way
now while the paper trail that may
result from work like this
can be somewhat cumbersome especially in
an age where nearly everything is
electronic
the compliance nevertheless is there
which we've proven
all this can be done as we have although
not without a good deal of effort
on the part of the executing laboratory
reassuring perhaps though is the notion
that in the near future
soon many of these aspects of data
integrity
may come built in to the um to the
software
making gmp-compliant auc more of an
off-the-shelf reality
so that being said i'll round out the
data portion
of this presentation with a few other
ways
beyond what i've shown in which auc can
also be applied to aav samples
the data portion of the talk so far has
been focused on the advantages of auc
as a means to characterize the mp full
distribution
or or the abundance of other species
such as partials
that may be present but beyond that the
benefits of auc can be extended
to other aav applications as well
specifically dual wavelengths
experiments can be done as i'll talk
about
and there's some richness of information
that can be gained there as well as
aggregation aggregation can be measured
apart from
the conventional distributions which
i've shown
which i'll also cover
and so conventional empty full
characterization is usually done at a
low uv wavelength like 230 nanometers
where absorptivity is very strong
and where there is likely to be relative
parity in terms of the absorbance
strength of empty and full capsids
however as is well known at longer
wavelengths we have some difference
between
the absorbance properties of proteins
versus nucleic acids
that is to say aromatic protein side
chains
clearly having a peak an absorbance peak
around 280 nanometers
while nucleic acid showing a much
stronger signal
uh lower at 260 nanometers so we can
take advantage of the disparity between
proteins and nucleic acid
and also take advantage of newer auc
instrumentation
which makes dual 260 280 detection easy
to do in a single experiment
so by doing so we can determine in a
single simple spin
if a certain peak is likely to be
associated with nucleic acids or not
in this example which highlights the
differential a260
and a280 signal of the empty peak
as i show here in these two graphs which
i toggle between
we see a much weaker a260 absorbance for
the empty peak
compared to the a280 absorbance
from the same from the peak that derives
from the same species now this is
expected for empty capsids
since they should in principle be all
protein and contain no nucleic acid
so the a260 signal is really just
residual very small
but the same principle can be applied to
other regions of the distribution
or may where it may be important to have
some idea of what the capsid identity
what the species identity is
now the data i show here is on a
well-behaved model system
but some products that we deal with have
a good deal of heterogeneity
around the main peak the main peak at
about 100s as i show in this graph
some samples may show a lot of broadness
in this region and in some cases have
resolvable shoulders
off of what is extensively the main peak
so the identity of these kinds what what
these what this broadness or what these
shoulders may correspond to
is a matter of some question in these
cases it may be very worthwhile to run a
dual 260 280
assay to investigate how the signal
varies between those two detection
wavelengths
which may shed some light on the source
of heterogeneity
in this crucial region
and so beyond just heterogeneity in the
neighborhood of the empty and full peaks
another important characteristic of an
aav sample
will be the extent of aggregates that
may be present while other methods
besides auc
have traditionally been used to measure
aggregation
notably size notably size exclusion hplc
and dynamic light scattering when it
comes to aggregation in aav
samples auc may have some advantages
over these other methods
specifically an auc separation has no
stationary phase or column matrix as
does
sec high molecular weight species which
may be present from capsid aggregation
can be trapped by hplc columns and
therefore missed by
these types of assays
now dls like auc has no stationary phase
but dls dynamic light scattering makes
no separation
of the capsid species and partly for
this reason
any size distribution information which
may be obtainable
by fitting dls data is lacking in the
kind of resolution
that an auc assay can provide
the data i show here was obtained by
subjecting an aav sample
to fairly strong thermal stress as
indicated in the graph
indicating that if aggregation does
occur
it is over a fairly large size range
many hundreds of s values indicated in
the figure
as demonstrated auc has the ability to
quantify aggregation
over this very large size range not only
that
at the same time it's able to resolve
some very real peak structure
over this range and that's a capability
that may not be possible
with other methods
that brings me to the end of uh we're
nearing the end of the presentation
and so in conclusion what i've
demonstrated in today's webinar
is that the auc assay when applied to
the characterization of recombinant aav
products
one provides excellent resolution of
empty full and other aav product
variants
on par or even superior to other methods
it's capable of meeting many of the
criteria for about many if not all
of the criteria for a validated method
including precision
linearity and robustness parameters that
make auc
fit for the purpose of quantifying
heterogeneity
in any of the clinical samples
three with the proper qa and csv
resources
uh the instrument and the assay can be
made to comply with data integrity
standards
and lastly with the right labor force uh
and instrumentation
with the right amount of personnel
and investment in hardware and
instrumentation
you see can be run at a throughput
suitable for most development needs
but not only that auc can do much more
it's very versatile
it can you can do now with the new
optima
multi-wavelength studies very easily and
studies on aggregation
making it a very competitive technique
overall when it comes to gene
delivery products
in closing i'll add just a few little
bits of information
um in a few and a few um a few graphs
illustrating the quite high tighter
levels
presently achieved in the production of
more conventional protein-based
therapeutics
some of these products in fact showing
at least a modest improvement in titer
over years of production again these are
for traditional protein-based drugs
which have been around much longer than
aavs or other drug or other gene
delivery
factors remarkably given the demand
for some of these products which are now
approved and produced at commercial
scale the raw amounts of these drugs
in terms of production can measure in
the hundreds of pounds or more
annually which is quite a remarkable
statistic
will recombinant aav products someday
also be produced in these large amounts
if so then certainly characterization
methods will have to be up to that
challenge
with this kind of market potential and
with today's instrumentation
allowing for improved data quality and
throughput if you are in the field of
gene therapy
consider asking what auc can do for you
and for your characterization needs
at charles river we are here to help in
that respect and also for any other
questions pertaining to biologic testing
my contacts are shown here and i'm happy
to be of service
i would ask that you also include this
address as well for proper routing
i'd like to give a special thanks to the
following individuals
kalala biswas the site director for
biologics in shrewsbury massachusetts
as well as the auc team consisting of
michael revit
nicholas macarthur and vivo who've done
many of
the experiments that form the basis for
this work
the other members of the biophysical
group you see listed here
and finally thank you for listening it's
been a pleasure to have been your host
for this presentation
just a few final slides here i have the
references that i've mentioned
throughout the talk
and lastly some disclaimer information
that concludes today's presentation
thank you again
and good day
thank you dr carter so this is for the
audience
while we take a moment and allow dr
sucato to catch his breath
we would like to put a question in front
of you
so the question is as follows we would
like to know
if auc is a future consideration
for your laboratory needs please please
select
one of the following options option a
not applicable i am already using auc
option b yes and i would like to speak
to a beckman cult or sales specialist
option c
yes but i prefer someone else runs my
sample
option d maybe but i'm still
unsure whether auc is a fixed for my
sample
and option e for no i do not foresee a
future need
for auc in my laboratory
thank you dr sukada for this extremely
informative
and very in-depth presentation we will
now start
the live q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for today
so let's get started the first question
we have in
is as follows this is a question about
experimental considerations how much
aav sample would you need to do
a basic characterization assay
and how much would you need for a full
validation
over to you dr zakat
thank you akash yeah that's a very good
question and
it's a question we get many times from
people that need to
get into aav studies for the first time
we're used to working with aav titers
that are in the
range of about one times e to a one e to
the thirteenth viral particles from
per ml a common tighter level that we
that we work with uh if you can have
tighter levels that high
we only really need about 100 or 200
microliters
to do a routine uh r d level test
um to carry and that would get you empty
full characterization
the presence of any partials or any
aggregates in the neighborhood of the
empty and full species
again that's about 100 to 200
microliters and that would get you
duplicate analysis
in a single single centrifugal
experiment
now a method validation as i've shown
involves many
many parts many parameters are evaluated
and so there's many assays that
that comprise a full validation for that
reason
the amounts required there are much more
on the order of
five milliliters at that same tighter
level
of about one e to the thirteenth
now while that might seem like a lot
we've noticed
over the course of several years that
that auc
has become an emerging method for aav
for for aav drug developers
that the amounts that are being able to
be produced from
improved manufacturing and um and
process improvements
make that more and more of a reality
those kind of amounts
so we we hope to see more process
improvements in the future that will
allow these kind of methods to go
forward
thank you dr sicardo so
the second question is very much in the
same context
does charles river laboratory also
perform any orthogonal or complementary
assays
for gene therapy products such as aav
yeah we do at charles river we have a
few complementary methods that are
available
and are known to the field in general
some of these are older techniques that
still have some utility
transmission electron microscopy or tem
has been traditionally used to
characterize aav products
and produces some nice image based
results
that's still done to some extent but as
the field
advances auc is quickly becoming the
method of choice as i say
is really becoming the front runner of
the gold standard for mp4
characterization
yet other assays are
receiving a lot of attention and a lot
of devel a lot of r d and optimization
efforts including
capillary electrophoresis based methods
including um
cief and isoelectric focusing
as well as ion exchange chromatography
now these methods may have some uh
improvements in the near in the very
near future
that um put its um
that put that put those methods in in
terms of the baseline resolution that
they can achieve
potentially on par with auc
at present we know of no method that can
surpass auc
in terms of the data quality the
separation of these peaks
the empty and the full the baseline
resolution and the good signal to noise
thank you dr zucato so we have two
related questions
coming up and they are both
on the analysis side of things so the
first of these questions is as follows
if a new commercial software was to be
developed for the analysis of auc data
especially focused upon gene therapy
samples
then what kind of computing modes
or models would you like to see
implemented
in such a software
uh thanks akash yeah so in terms of
the software and if these things if
these software
offerings become widely available in a
in an industry-friendly gmp-friendly way
then
then certainly the types of fitting
models i would like to see are
something akin to the traditional cfs
distribution
which is a standard
component of said fit which is a very
popular
algorithm so um clearly a c of s
model or um or a cfs-like model would be
an important factor
in anything that we would look for not
only that but
some models that are capable of
explicitly entering in discrete species
a cfs model makes no prior assumptions
as to how many peaks may be present
but some more advanced models might give
you the option of adding
in prior information about where certain
peaks might show up
which can aid in the fitting process so
that would be a nice
function to have as well as fitting
models that can
fit simultaneously both the
sedimentation coefficient as well as
information on shapes so sedimentation
coefficient
is very much a mass based very much
correlated with the mass of the species
but there's also some shape information
which may be
embedded within the auc data so a
fitting algorithm that can make
simultaneous sedimentation coefficient
and frictional ratio or diffusion
coefficient information
available from a single fit would be an
excellent attribute i think
thank you dr carter and the next
analysis question
which is very much on the line of gmp
which you have mentioned
a couple of times is this if such a
commercial software was to be
development
was to be developed and sorry then what
kind of gmp features
would you like it to have yeah that's
that's great and um clearly um any kind
of
um software offering in that regard
it should model what's what's present
in chromatography for example having um
password-based restrictions to entering
into the software
uh having audit trails uh for any
changes that we might might be made to a
method
or fitting um fitting parameters etc
having that auditable where the user is
required to acknowledge any changes and
that's tracked
the ability to lock methods as well as
data encryption so encryption of the raw
data
and proper storage or
maybe even server based filing of this
information
would be um very worthwhile i think
thank you dr sukado and thank you to the
audience for
asking these questions those are all of
the questions that we have time for
today
i want to remind our audience that those
questions
that we were unable to answer today and
those that come in
during the on-demand availability period
for this webinar will be answered via
the email address
that you provided at the time of
registration
before we go i would like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
again the questions that we were not
able to get to today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
that you've provided at the time of
registration
we would like to once again thank dr
sucato for his time today
and his valuable contributions to the
auc field
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor
beckman coulter life sciences for
underwriting
today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
thank you
and goodbye